[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing severus snape's iconic death
lily evans harry potter and the famous
lines that snape delivered
on his deathbed it's a line that's up
there with
always and you're a wizard harry and it
helps us to peel back the many layers of
snape's character
at the beginning of the books and films
snape is portrayed
as a bully an outlier a recluse
however this general perception of snape
only worsens over time
as he is later perceived to be evil a
cold-blooded
manipulative man who follows the dark
lord himself
there are certainly glimpses of a less
severe snape
that shine through but ultimately he is
portrayed as a dark
and brooding individual in the order of
the phoenix
harry gets a glimpse into snape's mind
during his legitimacy lesson
revealing the side of snape that harry
was not previously familiar with
in that one moment despite only seeing a
glimpse of what
lay in snape's mind harry learned more
about him than he had ever known
in spite of a total lack of context it
gave him
some small semblance of an idea as to
why snape was
the way that he was the subject of
incessant bullying
at the hands of harry's own father but
while this portion of the books and
films made us feel
something for snape this sympathy is
short-lived
as in the very next book film snape is
revealed to be a death eater
once again it's not until much later on
in the deathly hallows but snape finally
gets some proper redemption
at least in the eyes of harry watching
on harry witnesses first hand
snape's fatal attack from nagini when
the coast is clear
and voldemort and nagini are gone harry
approaches the dying professor
backed up against the wall slowly
bleeding out snape was in a state
unlike anything that harry had ever seen
before the strong
enigmatic snape was suddenly so helpless
and it's at this point that the idea is
planted in harry's mind
that perhaps snape isn't quite as bad as
he thought
he didn't know why but he knew that he
had to approach snape
in perhaps his bravest moment ever snape
died looking into the eyes of a boy
that was more significant to him than
harry even knew
this was the boy that shared the same
face of the man that bullied him for his
entire childhood
and the eyes of the only woman that he
ever loved
the same woman that spared her own life
to save this boy
with his final breaths in the film
version snape looked
straight into harry's face and uttered
the iconic line
you have your mother's eyes these were
the same eyes that caused snape
more pain than anything else in his
entire life but at the same time
they were the eyes that enabled snape to
feel love
to feel alive in the book he simply says
to harry
look at me and in the following chapter
after reviewing snape's memories
harry begins to understand the
significance of that line
he did not know why he was doing it why
he was approaching the dying man
he did not know what he felt as he saw
snape's white face
and the fingers trying to starch the
blood wound at his neck
harry took off the invisibility cloak
looked down upon the man he hated
whose widening black eyes found harry as
he tried to speak
harry bent over him and snape seized the
front of his robes and pulled him close
a terrible rasping gurgling noise issued
from snape's throat
take it take it something more than
blood was leaking from snape
silvery blue into gas nor liquid it
gushed from his mouth and his ears and
his eyes
and harry knew what it was but did not
know what to do
a flask conjured from thin air was
thrust into his shaking hands by
hermione
harry lifted the silvery substance into
it with his wand
when the flask was full to the brim and
snape looked as though there was no
blood left in him
his grab on harry's robes slackened look
at me he whispered
the green eyes found the black but after
a second
something in the depths of the dark pair
seemed to vanish
leaving them fixed blank and empty
the hand holding harry thudded to the
floor and snape
moved no more as we can see here
just before dying snape instructs harry
to collect his tears
tears that could reveal snape's full
story helping harry to understand
his tragedy to understand the prince's
tale
the stone pence of lay in the cabinets
where it had always been
harry heaved it onto the desk and poured
snape's memories
into the wide basin with its runic
markings around the edge
to escape into someone else's head would
be a blessed relief
nothing even snape had left him could be
worse than his own thoughts
when harry approached the pensive he was
exhausted withered and war-torn
and ultimately it was his willingness to
escape his unreality
it allowed him to fully dive into and
absorb what he was witnessing in the
memories of snape
he fearlessly allowed himself to become
immersed in snape's world
his reality and it was here that he
began to piece together snape's full
story
it started right at the beginning when
harry witnessed a young boy that was
familiar and
unfamiliar all at the same time this boy
looked like snape
but he was happy he had a smile on his
face
and he had a companion harry's mother
lily
the pair were in the muggle town of coke
worth where they grew up together
and life was good tragically this was
the happiest time of snape's entire life
the period that preceded 27 years of
heartache
when it came time for the young pair to
embark on their journey to hogwarts
they took the train together leaving
lily's sister petunia
behind however what was supposed to be
the most exciting time of snape's life
quickly became his worst nightmare as
him and lily
were sorted into different houses lily
to gryffindor
and snape to slytherin it wasn't enough
to sever the connection entirely
but it was enough to cause him to
gradually drift apart
going down two very different paths
snape hung out with the wrong crowd
some of which would later become
followers of lord voldemort and lily
openly expressed her concerns
surrounding the kinds of people snape
was associating himself with
in an argument one day snape calls lily
a filthy mudblood
an insult which he immediately and
frantically retracts
however for lily it was a last straw and
it ended things between them
forever next harry sees a very different
snape
an older snape begging and pleading with
none other than albus dumbledore
on a hilltop at that time snape was a
full-fledged death eater
but here he was pleading with the leader
of the opposition
why as their exchange continues harry
begins to understand what was going on
snape had observed trelloni predicting
the fabled prophecy
and relay that information to voldemort
overcome with guilt
and knowing that voldemort's knowledge
of this prophecy directly put lily's
life
in jeopardy snape had no other choice
than to go to dumbledore
the only wizard powerful enough to
directly oppose lord voldemort
and protect lily the next memory that
harry witnesses
is after the tragedy at godric's hollow
had already occurred
after lily and james had been killed he
sees snape in dumbledore in dumbledore's
office
and harry witnessed firsthand snape
agreeing to devote his life to harry
to protect him in lilly's honor after
reviewing snape's memories
harry begins to see his old potions
professor in a different light
gone was the murky bitter death eater
that he'd grown to hate
for in harry's mind and heart there was
a place for redemption in snape
this is reflected by harry later naming
one of his own children
after the man that he'd hated for so
many years the prince's tale
the 33rd chapter of the deathly hallows
is one of my favorite chapters
from the entire franchise as it finally
reveals snape's true nature to harry
snape wasn't a dark and troubled man of
his own volition he was a man
perpetually haunted by his past
he was neglected by his parents rejected
by the one girl that he ever loved
only to witness her marry his school
bully and later endured a stressful life
as a double agent in an ongoing
wizarding war i know that there are
plenty of fans that have an undulating
perception of snape
some finished harry potter the feeling
that a little bit of good in snape
was not nearly enough to offset the bad
while others felt that snape
was certainly deserving of some form of
sympathy a man that was soured
by his own tragic existence the moral
ambivalence surrounding snape's
character
is perhaps what makes him so enigmatic
and the divisive opinions toward his
character
make him one of the most interesting
talking points from the franchise
i'm eager to find out after you all had
finished the books
and films what was your perception of
snape
was he worthy of redemption let me know
in the comment section
below until next time you have your
mother's eyes
[Music]
you